-Hey, guys. I'm here with
the one and only
Jennifer Lopez,
and we're about to play
the "Watch-It-Once
TikTok Challenge."
♪♪
-♪ Watch-It-Once
TikTok Challenge ♪
♪ Watch-It-Once
-Okay, here's how it works.
Jennifer and I are going to
watch a TikTok challenge
that neither one of us
has ever seen before.
And we're going to try to
re-create it.
And whoever gets closest to it
wins that round.
You down for this?
-Yeah, I'm going to go down
and play in front of my kids.
It's fine.
-Well, I think I'm gonna be
pretty good at this 'cause --
-Like,
"Mom, don't embarrass us!"
[ Laughter ]
-I'm kind of known for
my dancing.
So this is going to be --
-Yes.
-This is going to be
easy for me, I think.
I just want to get to a space.
Okay. All right.
Here we go. Like that.
Okay.
All right.
Here's the first TikTok dance.
[ Slow music playing ]
♪♪
All right, so now
it's my turn to go.
I can't see the dance.
I just got to try to re-create
in my brain
what it was to the music.
-Okay.
-I'm going to go first.
Here we go.
[ Slow music playing ]
♪♪
-Yes!
Okay!
[ Music stops ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Indistinct chatter ]
-It's your turn.
It's your turn.
[ Slow music playing ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Applause ]
How'd you know?
Oh, my gosh!
-Okay.
-Oh, come on now.
Let's watch both of ours
together,
and see which one got closer.
-Okay.
♪♪
-Awww, you crushed me!
-We both did good on that one!
-You crushed me on that one!
Come on.
-No, we both did good
on that one.
You did it perfectly.
-I think you're very --
also, you're very cheery.
You're very happy,
like, when you're doing that.
I'm not. My face is
concerned when I dance.
All right, let's look at
the next dance.
Here's the next dance.
It's a little bit harder.
-I hope they're all that easy.
-♪ It was nice to nice
to know you ♪
♪ Let's do it again ♪
♪ How we did it
on a one night stand ♪
-Oh, oh, oh!
-All right, that's
Charli D'Amelio.
All right, okay, here we go.
Jennifer, you go first.
You go first this time.
-♪ It was nice to nice
to know you ♪
♪ Let's do it again ♪
♪ How we did it
on a one night stand ♪
-What? How did you do that?
Oh, my goodness.
All right. All right.
Let me try to do mine.
-The worst.
-This is so silly.
-Let's do it again.
-Yeah.
-♪ It was nice to nice
to know you ♪
♪ Let's do it again ♪
♪ How we did it
on a one night stand ♪
-[ Laughing ]
Oh, my gosh.
All right, I don't even know if
I have to watch that one back.
I think you won on that one.
-You got the beginning,
I think.
-I think I got
the beginning and ending,
just the middle I just
was a wash.
-♪ It was nice to nice
to know you ♪
♪ Let's do it again ♪
♪ How we did it
on a one night stand ♪
-Okay! You got that one.
You crushed that one.
You got that one. All right.
This is the third one.
This is the third level hardest.
Here we go.
-♪ Turn me on till
the early morn ♪
♪ Let's get it on,
let's get it on ♪
♪ Till the early morn
Girl, it's all good ♪
♪ Just turn me on
Yo, shake that thing ♪
♪ Miss, Cana, Cana
shake that thing ♪
♪ Yo Annabella ♪
-All right, I'm ready
to try mine.
-♪ Turn me on till
the early morn ♪
♪ Let's get it on,
let's get it on ♪
♪ Till the early morn
Girl, it's all good ♪
-Do it!
-♪ Just turn me on ♪
Yo, shake that thing ♪
♪ Miss, Cana, Cana
shake that thing ♪
♪ Yo Annabella ♪
-I'm gonna end all my dances
with that now.
-[ Laughs ]
-All right.
[ Music playing ]
-Wait, wait, wait!
I'm not ready. I'm not ready.
I'm not ready. I'm sorry.
Kids are distracting me.
One more time, one more time.
One more time.
Okay, ready?
The first thing is tap, tap.
Okay, go.
-♪ Turn me on till
the early morn ♪
♪ Let's get it on,
let's get it on ♪
♪ Till the early morn
Girl, it's all good ♪
♪ Just turn me on
Yo, shake that thing ♪
♪ Miss, Cana, Cana
-[ Laughs ]
-♪ Shake that thing
Yo Annabella ♪
[ Laughter ]
-That's so good.
-Wait --
-That is so good.
No, we've got to see it again.
It's so funny.
-♪ Turn me on ♪
♪ Till the early morn ♪
-I was like, I remembered
there was a thing
on the thing.
-Yeah, I know, you --
Oh, gosh.
That was great. All right.
You got props on that one too.
This last one,
I believe we just got snuck
this in, is from you?
-Oh, yeah.
-"World of Dance"?
-I just made this up, okay?
so I have to remember it too.
You have to do this one.
-All right, it's a
"World of Dance" challenge.
Is this out yet?
-No, we're about to put it out.
You try it first.
Tell me if it's fun.
-All right.
Let me watch it.
-♪ And dance ♪
♪ Love ♪
♪ And dance again ♪
♪ I want to dance ♪
♪ And love ♪
♪ And dance again ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
-Got it?
-Oh, it's so easy. It's cake.
[ Laughter ]
All right, let's just try it.
I have no idea what this is
going to be.
-Okay.
-♪ And dance ♪
♪ Love ♪
♪ And dance again ♪
♪ I want to dance ♪
♪ And love ♪
♪ And dance again ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
-Hey!
That wasn't bad.
-That was awful.
There's no way.
-It's hard to do these
in one thing.
These kids, they take hours to
do their TikToks
and get them right.
Maybe not hours.
-You are the best.
Thank you so much.
I'm out of breath.
-Thank you, baby.
-Thank you for playing with me.
I will interview you
right after this. Is that okay?
-Yes, let's do it.
-I'm going to go get some water.
You're the best!
Jennifer Lopez!